hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy here it's today's
rules you must completely use the food
given you can on be out to the food you
can buy whatever ingredients you wish
let's see what we are making fancy today
tater tots I've tried this before and I
think it's delicious the first time I
saw this it was in a movie called
Napoleon Dynamite I really like that
it's just very simple potato and salt
and fry but I haven't tried them for a
long time so I want to refresh my memory
cute that's just I like this because
it's crunchy salty potato II so this is
delicious as they its but this is not
too fancy so I want to transform there's
something very impressive
okay I've got some great ideas and I'm
excited to make it fancy right yeah
that's what I got dried porcini
mushrooms onion rosemary garlic thyme
shiitake mushrooms butter ground alum
heavy cream Carol and eggs from the
pantry I got beef stock flour salt
no-stick spray wash shires water Shia
washy Shire sauce and red wine okay
let's get started
Thank You Frankie first we are going to
soak porcini mushroom I have 1 cup of
hot water this is one own stride porcini
mushroom soak this about 30 minutes set
this aside and start chopping vegetables
I've never met mushroom I didn't like
there ain't expensive mushroom in Japan
though called the matsutake its costs
about $100 a mushroom fragrance it's
really strong and it's very good we are
missing only like small dice and I'm
going to just peel you see the skinniest
Carol I've ever seen at the same size
they are going to be
in the same pose I'm going to just mix
together mushroom it's soaked so you
want to use the soaking water later so
don't discard chopped mushroom similar
side-streets only on a Carol it's
softened so it's easier to cut we also
have shiitake mushroom remove the stem
so we are just using this part you want
to cut all the ingredients almost the
same size so it's cooks evenly we're
using different mushroom because it has
a different texture and a different
flavor so all the shiitake mushroom 8
stock cut garlic next I have a lot of
knife at home but the why use them all
see it's a chef's knife and this it's
petit 950 knife is good knife when you
are cutting small things like garlic's
or like cutting fruits so if you want to
start cooking I highly recommend to get
chef's knife and petty knife first so
they're ready to go and we are moving on
to next step heat up olive oil medium
high to ground along so you kind of want
to make it small pieces so using glue
the spatula and a break to me cook it
until it changes color I'm using LAN for
this recipe if you don't have love you
can use ground beef season weeds so I'm
pepper you can see a load of oil can
flow up so you want to drain it after
okay so it looks good the reason you
drain the oil you don't want to make the
final dish too super greasy so next we
are going to use the same pan but you
want to wipe the excess grease add a
little bit olive oil subbed a [ __ ]
double on your anamcara
first season with a little bit salt when
you're cooking a lot of vegetables
season one by one so you kind of
flailing the flavor if you sprinkle salt
on
onions or Kara it kind of helps soft and
faster okay so earlier it's softened
shiitake mushrooms porcini mushrooms and
garlic and I'm sauteing with medium
until all the ingredients get softer for
about seven to eight minutes I tended to
put garlic to other to the end because
they sometimes it's get burnt
sometime a little bit more salt and I'm
adding back the lump 1/2 cup of wine 2
tablespoon flour I added red wine
because it's go well with love and it's
adds depth of flavor and are the 2 cups
of beef stock we are also adding washer
schuster wash your shire 2 tbsp bring
this to a boil and reduce the heat to
simmer simmer about 20 to 30 minutes
until the sauce thickens
okay so sauce has been thickened it's a
good consistency transfer to wring mode
so you want to spray the mold with a
little bit oil to filling into the mold
if you don't have ring mold you can just
put it in a bowl or ramekin flatten it
with spatula so it's easy when you are a
mold you said this aside you're moving
on to next step tater tots time one
pound of tater tots and a pudding in a
steamer box put the lid back on top and
steam this about ten to twelve minutes
okay it's been ten minutes
transfer this into a bowl I'm adding in
date eraser somehow a lot of cooking
tool look like a torture device it's
making its when you make mashed potato
you want to use this one so you can make
like nice creamy mashed potato tater
tots it's a little bit grainy and I
wanted to make smooth mashed potato kind
of texture isn't America
yeah I think tater tops it's really cute
I you cannot beat that
if you don't have potato ricer you can
use potato masher or you can use
fork but don't use food processor
because it makes potato very gummy 2
tablespoon of heavy cream full
tablespoon of melted butter I'm going to
use two egg yolks
I learned tater tots either scrubs from
French fries so it's not waste food
which is great taste in OST and season
with salt mix everything evenly combined
well and I'm moving on to the next step
we have this potato mixture and I have
piping bag you can kind of twist and
insert I think actually that's a strip
or you can use something tall like a
glass you kind of want to pipe this kind
of experimenting with style you can also
do kind of like lines so if you don't
have a mold or if you don't have piping
back you can just use casserole it
doesn't need to be fancy but this sure
is make you Francis I'm making fancy so
I'm going to bake this in oven 375 be on
high for 20 to 25 minutes until potato
its golden brown I will need 2 cups of
beef stock and using weeds our mushroom
soaking water you want to strain through
mesh sieve so it catches those like
sun's and stuff one cup of soaking water
3 sprigs of thyme and garlic you don't
need to chop this you just like want to
smash it and bring it to a boil and
reduce to simmer and reduce the sauce by
half so the flavor it's concentrated
okay so sauce is reduced by half as you
can see the color its darkened
add butter to stick in the sauce I'm
adding 2 tbsp butter and make sure use
the cold butter to emulsify the sauce if
you use warm butter or if you use melted
butter the sauce won't be emulsified and
it will break I'm adding one more
you want to whisk constantly since we
use thyme and garlic you want to strain
sauce it's done and we are moving on to
next step so we baked about 25 minutes
the potato looks golden brown it looks
delicious so I'm going to plate it make
it pretty
Roda to fancy transferring this sauce to
little gravy PAH moment of truth and a
final touch top of the rosemary and we
are done
[Music]
pater thoughts trip on spy very fancy
[Music]
Ryan
yay welcome to Peter tops love dolly
Tater Tot Wonderland cool that's awesome
yeah love tater tots yeah tater tots
have always been with me and when they
haven't been with me I have sought them
out what do you think like wow it's this
I think that's like it looks like a
succulent it looks like sweated onions
yeah that's right mmm what do you write
no chicken beef no yes
make it baby right Katie can you guess
what I made a fancy today it looks like
shepherd's pie but I don't I can't tell
from here what you've made fancy yeah so
this is like a gravy yeah I can only
tell right now that it looks like mashed
potatoes on the top mm-hmm best
shepherd's pie I've ever had yes well I
won't have like Trader Joe's when I eat
the topper alone it tastes a little bit
like hashbrowns
yes and I don't know is they a Walmart
as it at a turd can I just take the rest
oh yeah of course it's like my bedtime
yeah but then time you should pass by
the barium ADEs tin Todd's fence and
make it fit make it friendly
[Music]
[Music]